من النبات والحديث عن بنك البذور الى
اللغات هذه المره احرف ونقوش ورموز تركها
الانباط في موقع الحجر الاثري في العلا
حيث عاشوا هناك لقرون من الزمان النقوش
النبطيه جزء من تاريخ العلا وسحر المدينه
وهي مقصد اللغويين والمؤرخين حيث تسطر
ذكراهم وحضارتهم الخالده جذور اللغه
النبطيه القديمه تعود الى اللغه العربيه
وهي واحده من اولى اللغات المكتوبه
المحفوره والمعروفه في العالم وكذلك اللغه
الدوليه لتجاره في الالفيه الاولى قبل
الميلاد وفي عام 20 21 اعلنا معاهدوا
اللغات اضافه لحصص لتعلم اللغه النبطيه في
خطوه لحفظ ابجديات اللغه النبطيه وايضا
لاصحاب ضيوف العلا في رحله عبر الزمن من
اجل استكشاف كنوز حضارتها القديمه وملامح
ارثها العريق
[موسيقى]
اذا سنكون هنا مع ضيفنا في مجلسنا في
العلا سيد ماهر الغزاوي مدير معهد اللغات
يسعد صباحك استاذ ماهر
ميدو مشاكل على الاستضافه وسعيد جدا
بتواجد معكم اليوم
بالعاده يا استاذ ماهر اللغه تكسر الحواجز
اللغه تساعد على التواصل بشكل اكبر بيننا
كبشر فبالتالي ما اهميه معهد اللغات في
العلا
الانجليزيه والفرنسيه
استاذ ماهر يبدو انه هناك في مشكله في
الصوت
سنحاول يعني ان نعود الى جمهور الذي يتابع
اليوم بعد قليل في سياق هذه الفقره الحديث
اكثر عن معهد اللغات
وبالتاكيد ايضا على تدريس اللغه النبطيه
يعني هذا امر لافت لانه تحدث عن مملكه
الانباط التي نشات هنا واتخذت من شمال غرب
المملكه العربيه السعوديه مكانا لها
لحضارتها طبعا كل النقوش التي نراها سواء
في المناطق التاريخيه والجبال مثلا جبل
عكمه نرى نقوش نبطيه وهذه النقوش هي تدل
على اللغه النبطيه ولكي نفهم اكثر كيف
تطورت اللغه العربيه على كل حال الان جهز
الصوت على امل ان شاء الله خير طيب استاذ
ماهر خلينا نعيد كمان مره نتحدث عن اهميه
معهد اللغات في العلوم عهد اللغات يمثل
معهد مركز الثقافي لغوي لاهالي العلاوي
تبع المحلي بحيث يضم في جنباته خمس لغات
مختلفه هي اللغه الانجليزيه والفرنسيه
والعربيه لغير الناطقين بها والصينيه
واللغه النبطيه همم وكذلك اليوم المعهد
يعتبر مركز رئيسي لاختبار الايلتس للغه
الانجليزيه والاختبار الدلفي اللغه
الفرنسيه
طبعا يمكن الشقه الاكبر يروح للغه
الانجليزيه تمام نعم بحكم اليوم همم
المجتمع المحلي يحتاج ان يكون مسلح باللغه
الانجليزيه للانخراط في السوق العمل وكذلك
لتسريحهم بالمهارات المطلوبه ل- همم
للسفر خارج المملكه او للالتحاق بالجامعه
المحليه
طب جميل اليوم بيقولوا لك انه من يتابع
نقوش العلا خصوصا على الجدران نتحدث يعني
عن اكبر مكتبه مفتوحه في العالم اذا ما
ذهبنا الى جبل عكمه نرى هذه النقوش لو
تحدثنا عن اللغه النبطيه تاريخ ما هي
اللغه النبطيه همم
اليوم اللغه النبطيه بحكم المعالم
التاريخيه والانسانيه المتواجده في العلا
والتي تسخر فيها العلا ونشات مملكه
الانباط المرتده على مساحه 800 كم من شمال
المملكه همم وصول الى العلا وتحديدا موقع
الحجر موقع الحجر يمثل همم الموقع الاثري
الذي يستقطب همم السياح والزوار من شتى
همم انحاء العالم نهيك انه موقع الحجر
يعتبر الموقع الرسمي الاول للمملكه
العربيه السعوديه الذي تم ادراجه في قائمه
التراث العالمي في اليونسكو طيب استاذ
ماهر خلينا نشوف هاي اللوحه اللي حضرتك
جبتها معك ونفرجيها كمان همم على الكاميرا
طيب خلينا نشوف هاي اللوحه اذا
لوحه مكتوب عليها باللغه النبطيه صباح
العربيه في العلا اذا هذه اللوحه مكتوب
عليها صباح العربيه في العلا هذه هي
الاحرف النبطيه ومن خلال هذه الاحرف
النبطيه تم فهم اكثر للغه العربيه
من اللغه النبطيه وحيث كانت اللغه النبطيه
تملك 22 حرف انا ذاكر نعم اوكي
الاحرف الموجوده
في اكثر من منطقه اكثر
في الحجر وكذلك في معظم همم
ابرز المعالم الموجوده في العلماء طيب هل
يمكن ان تحدثنا عن عدد المستفيدين من هذه
البرامج في معهد اللغات
الخمسه لغات وصل العدد المستفيدين
والمستفيدات اذا اجازه التعبير الى
1,167 مستفيد
حصه الكبرى رايحه للامكن يعني ذهبت للغه
الانجليزيه ولكن هو تحديدا للغه النبطيه
المستفيدين 40 شخص
نعم
كل هذه المعلومات ماهر الغزاوي مدير معهد
شكرا
اذا مشاهدينا من هذا المجلس من مجلسنا في
العلا وصباح العربيه في العلا سهام انا
معاكي سهام هذه رح ناخذها معنا لدبي انا
بنستناها منك تجيب اللوحه معاكي نادين انت
تجولتي في موقع الحجر شاهدتها النقوش بام
العين دين
انا شهاده سهام هذه النقوش في اكثر من
منطقه حقيقه ولكن العدد الاكبر منها موجود
في جبل عكمه يعني هذا الجبل منذ ان تدخل
الجبل بين الجبال وبين الصخور الجبليه تري
كل اشكال هذه الاحرف اللي هي احرف النبطيه
وايضا الى جانب الاحرف سهام ايضا شاهدنا
رسومات مثلا رسومات لالات موسيقيه وكان
الانباط كانوا يحبون كثيرا الموسيقى مثلا
لناس معينين هيئات اشخاص هناك رسمات ربما
كانوا يريدون ان يبقوا رسائل للبشريه من
بعضهم ولي الاجيال التي ستالي من بعدهم
بعد مئات الاف السنين لكي يعرف ماذا كان
يفعل الانباط هنا شكرا جزيلا شكرا لضيفك
الكريم على هذه التغطيه من العلاج